want to learn faster than everyone else
here's the secret your brain isn't
broken it's brilliantly designed did you
know your brain processes 11 million
bits of information every
second but here's the catch your
conscious mind can only handle 40 bits
that's why most learning methods feel
like drinking from a fire hose but what
if you could work with your brain
instead of against it for example your
attention isn't a flood light it's a
laser focus it strategically L and
you'll lock in information faster than
ever here's another game Cher forgetting
isn't your enemy it's your brain's way
of saying hey review this now use the
forgetting curve to your advantage and
you'll remember more with less effort
and timing it's everything your brain
has peak hours for memory creativity and
problem solving learn when your brain is
ready and you'll unlock Next Level
results ready to transform how you learn
watch watch the full video and discover
the science-backed system to learn
faster remember more and master any
skill your brain's already capable let's
unlock its full potential